em meados do século 19 os cientistas
acreditavam que o código da vida deveria
ser feito de proteína
afinal as proteínas são estruturas
celulares complexas envolvidos em
quebras de montagem dentro da célula e
são indispensáveis para a formação de
estruturas ainda mais robusta como os
tecidos e órgãos
no entanto com o passar do tempo e com a
licitação da estrutura tridimensional
dna por último em click ficava cada dia
mais evidente que acabou aquela molécula
estável
formada por duas fitas complementares e
com facilidade para ser copiada é que
era o código da vida
as quatro letras a c t g então toda
informação química necessária para
produzir um ser vivo completo
essas quatro letras são informação
química que codifica todo o tipo de vida
na terra desde a mais simples bactéria
até o maior dos mamíferos dos mares
a baleia azul passando pelo animal
chamado homosapiens popularmente
conhecido como homem
no entanto parece haver algo de
esquisito em afirmar que o código da
vida é o mesmo
se olhamos para o lado e demos tamanha
diversidade não é mesmo dentro das
diferentes populações humanas por
exemplo
olhamos para o lado devemos prontamente
diferentes cores da pele formatos da
fazem o tipo de cabelo
olhando pra toda essa variedade uma
pessoa poderia perguntar será que
deveríamos nos nosso genoma
será que existem conseqüências
definitivas dos nossos genomas que
recebi não separarem definitivamente de
outras populações humanas nos últimos
dez anos
com o sequenciamento do genoma humano eo
desenvolvimento de técnicas de
seqüenciamento rápidas e baratas
suficiente nos permitirão seqüenciar o
genoma de diversas pessoas de diversas
populações humanas como o projeto para
sequenciar 1000 genomas humanos e nos
permitiram dar uma resposta curada e
definitiva para essa questão
os genomas humanos variam das três
bilhões de letras a c t g que formam o
genoma humano
pelo menos 38 milhões delas vão variar
entre os indivíduos
no entanto
pelo menos 85 por cento dessas variações
são encontradas entre indivíduos
pertencentes à mesma população
isso significa dizer que mesmo pessoas
pertencentes ao mesmo grupo étnico terão
genomas que irão variar grandemente
em outras palavras olhando apenas para o
genoma e das regiões variáveis desse
genomas um cientista não consegue dizer
que aquelas pessoas pertencem ao mesmo
grupo étnico ou se estão separadas no
globo por milhares de quilômetros de
distância pois as variações no genoma se
distribuem de forma quase igual dentro
das populações e entre elas
por isso a diversidade de
características físicas que vemos quando
olhamos para as pessoas como cor da pele
o formato da face
não são geradas por pequenos gênios com
grandes efeitos por pequenas sequências
definitivas do código que os de nos
diferenciar iam definitivamente de
outras pessoas mas sim são formadas por
uma variedade de variantes genéticas e
que variam com frequências diferentes e
à medida que o ser humano se desloca
mais e mais ao redor do globo e se
reproduz fica cada vez mais difícil
traçar a centralidade de alguém baseado
nos seus traços fenotípicos nas suas
características físicas visíveis porque
uma pessoa pode ter a pele clara mas
devido ao histórico de viagens dos seus
antepassados ela pode com é possuir um
extra africano e pode possuir a
predisposição genética para ter uma
doença genética que não está ligado à
cor da pele por isso nem por razões
médicas se justifica preparar as
populações humanas pelas chamadas raças
porque por mais que uma pessoa se
considere branca e que seu médico
enxergue que ela é branca
se ela tiver um ancestral longínquo
africano ela pode ter a predisposição
genética para ter a doença nem me
falciforme traço genético que não está
ligado à cor da pele mas que têm alta
incidência em populações do oeste
africano
por isso antes de entrar para a história
disposição genética de uma pessoa
baseado nos seus traços fenotípicos vale
muito mais a pena um médico perguntar
qual é a sua história ea dos seus
antepassados
além disso a diversidade que chegamos no
mundo estão relacionadas às variáveis
genéticas mas também estão relacionadas
a fatores ambientais
o genoma com tem a potencialidade de um
indivíduo mas a expressão dessa
informação vai variar devido a fatores
ambientais escolha hábitos de vida
por isso o nosso material genético não é
o nosso destino final
a forma como vivemos a vida influencia
em última instância em que nós vamos
realmente ser o mesmo acontece quando
olhamos para a variedade animal e
vegetal que vemos no planeta terra
no caso das diferenças inter específicas
formando diferentes espécies animais e
vegetais
as diferenças no código genético são
mais profundas do que as encontradas
entre dois seres humanos se pensarmos no
genoma como um livro
podemos dizer que as diferentes espécies
são formadas por livros de diferentes
espessuras diferentes número de páginas
olhem as frases e das letras
além dos fatores ambientais que vão
criar a universidade
mesmo dentro da mesma espécie animal mas
o código da vida que potencializa todo
tipo de vida na terra é exatamente o
mesmo
o código de letras a c t g
somos todos formados pelo código da vida
qual é a conclusão mais simples que
podemos tirar é a de que todos nós desde
bactérias e até seres humanos somos
aparentados
defendemos todos em última instância de
um mesmo ancestral comum que iniciou sua
vida na terra há mais ou menos 4.5
milhões de anos
a meu ver é a constatação é a de que
todos nós possuímos um mesmo ancestral
comum deveria nos fazer sentir apenas
uma coisa humildade e deveria nos fazer
ter respeito por todo o tipo de vida na
terra não só por seres humanos os
chimpanzés com quem compartilhamos um
ancestral comum é recente mas como todo
tipo de vida pois longinquamente ou não
pertencemos todos a mesma árvore da vida
no entanto pela forma como temos
interagido com o mec
cerca dificultando ativamente utilizando
outras espécies como recurso de forma
insustentável
não me parece que temos mostrado
respeito algum se não somente porque a
diversidade é linda e deve ser
preservada prever precisamos mudar a
forma como interagimos com o make no
serra para que nós seres humanos
tenhamos alguma oportunidade de
sobreviver
pesquisas recentes têm mostrado que o
impacto do homem na terra tem levado a
uma diminuição da biodiversidade a taxas
tão alarmantes quando as encontradas nos
momentos que precederam as quatro
maiores distinções em março passado
anualmente desaparecem para sempre do
planeta terra entre 11 mil e 36 mil
espécies animais cada uma das espécies
representa um papel decisivo na
manutenção do equilíbrio dos nossos
ecossistemas
a perda de cada uma dessas espécies e
seus efeitos em cadeia e leva em última
instância a diminuição da produção de
comida
a diminuição da descoberta e produção de
novos medicamentos a mais e mais
instituições e de forma mais acelerada
os fatores que contribuem para a perda
da biodiversidade vai ver um para os
diferentes ecossistemas
no caso dos ecossistemas terrestres o
fator número um da perda da
biodiversidade é o desmatamento das
florestas para produção de áreas de
pasto ou plantações
no caso de ecossistemas aquáticos a
pesca predatória é o fator número um nos
ecossistemas de água doce a poluição ea
presença de espécies invasoras são dois
dos grandes problemas o meu trabalho de
doutorado na universidade federal do rio
de janeiro é uma forma de lidar com
esses problemas como lidar com espécies
invasoras e mitigar os seus efeitos
nossa abordagem no laboratório envolve
investigação genética do mexilhão
dourado científicamente chamado
limnoperna fortunei um balneário que
está espalhado nas nossas vagas
sul-americanas mexilhão dourado chegou
pela primeira vez à américa do sul em
1990 no porto de buenos aires
trazido da água em água de lastro de
navios e se espalhou rapidamente pelos
aquífero da américa do sul até o
pantanal
agindo como um poderoso engenheiro de
ecossistemas o mexilhão dourado diminui
a biodiversidade dos locais invadidos
além de entupir tubulações de usinas
hidrelétricas sistema de abastecimento
de água por si e se reproduzir
descontroladamente
o mexilhão dourado ameaça à
biodiversidade da amazônia e para
encontrar uma estratégia exclusivo e
efetiva de controle antes que ele chegue
até lá que estamos trabalhando para
encontrar essa estratégia efetiva de
controle
eu estou voltando lá no livro da vida
que potencializa vida da espécie
eu estou seqüenciando e montando o
genoma do mexilhão dourado
nossa estratégia envolve encontraram
algo genético específico para o mexilhão
que possamos atingir com ferramentas de
engenharia genética e para que possamos
diminuir e quando possível eliminar uma
estrela das nossas águas e que não seja
da novo para as espécies nativas
essa abordagem utilizar estudos
genômicos como uma forma de preservar a
biodiversidade é apenas uma das várias
abordagens científicas que tem sido
utilizada em prol da preservação da
biodiversidade
um outro exemplo inclui a criação de
espécies ameaçadas de extinção em
cativeiro ea reintrodução dessas
espécies em locais naturais trabalho
difícil longo iniciativa heróico dos
nossos cientistas que pensa na
preservação da biodiversidade
no entanto o que nós precisamos entender
é que nenhuma dessas iniciativas
científicas será suficiente se não
mudarmos a forma como interagimos com o
meio que nos cerca
continuamos aumentando a população
humana taxas alarmantes ea distribuição
de renda e recursos é extremamente
desigual e esses problemas sociais e
econômicos são em último em última
instância os causadores dos nossos
problemas ambientais e esses são
problemas solucionáveis junto com as
mudanças sociais e econômicas
necessárias
o conjunto de soluções científicas e
tecnológicas são um conjunto perfeito de
soluções para mantermos o equilíbrio do
nosso ecossistema e não somente por um
motivo de sobrevivência mas por respeito
devemos manter esse equilíbrio
afinal a nossa
diversidade tem origem comum todos nós
temos o mesmo material genético
somos unidade na diversidade obrigada